hey everyone this is Steve ponchope with
collider and I'm here in the collider
Studio sponsored by Saratoga spring
water thank you Saratoga uh Sundance
it's expensive and we appreciate our
sponsors with the filmmaker and cast
behind
um I believe it's called shortcomings
shortcomings here we are
um I was gonna mess mess around with the
title but I'm going to be serious and
say congratulations I believe this is
your first feature that you have
directed yes yes thank you so much and
so I am cured well listen actually
everyone watching this interview will
not have seen the movie yet so or maybe
two people will have so how have you
been describing the film to friends and
family
uh
I've been bad at it uh but I I what I
usually say is it's about uh three Bay
Area
uh urbanites
who uh uh are uh uh making a lot of
mistakes in life but trying their best
that's what I usually say it's kind of
vague
do you guys describe it a different way
or
a key phrase for me is Slice of Life
it's very just people having
conversations it's very raw and perfect
those are some keywords without spoilers
I think it's definitely like Randall was
saying kind of a hard movie to sum up
because we talked a lot about how the
arcs of these characters it's not like
you know
um you know crazy like sci-fi or
anything like that it's just about these
these three people that are kind of
finding themselves in Berkeley and then
end up in New York it's also I think
you've left out that it's funny
oh thank you yes thank you
but one of the things that I uh
appreciated is that it it is exploring
what it means to be Asian American in a
new way on screen it's expanding
um you know it's it's expanding I don't
want to say a genre but it's expanding
the characters of of what's been
depicted and can you sort of talk about
is that the main reason or one of the
main reasons why this material was so
important to you yeah you know when I
read the uh graphic novel uh that Adrian
uh tomina wrote and uh and and he also
wrote the screenplay but when I read his
graphic novel uh 15 years ago I was just
so so struck by
how real and authentic it felt and and
and you know I was around the same age
as these characters at the time and uh
and I just felt like it it felt like my
life in a lot of ways and people that I
knew and places that I've been and uh
and that was really mind-blowing for me
at that time specifically because I had
never seen that reflected back at me in
in any kind of media you know uh uh so
the thought of telling a story like this
where it's really like
what we do every day which is to hang
out go to restaurants talk about our
lives I mean to to make a movie like
that was uh was particularly exciting
for me
yeah I think the themes of this film is
like people growing apart you know
people uh just
sabotaging almost you know people who
are just so flawed and it's because of
the mainstream hits that have afforded
us
um this kind of movie you know that's so
it could not be more simple it could not
be more just people talking could not be
more just like just about relationships
like Ali said there's no alien
abductions or car chases you know what I
mean it's literally just people and I
think that's the most universal thing
about this movie it's just so human and
we've never had a movie like this just
when we watch it I was like whoa I was
blown away because it felt so modern and
overdue yet it felt like this classic
that we've been missing for so long you
know I I'm definitely curious uh your
character uh Ben I believe is um he can
be a little bit abrasive a little
difficult but the secret is that you
play him in a way that the audience
still is rooting and caring for him can
you sort of talk about
um inhabiting this role and finding that
line of where Ben is
I think for me it was just always about
finding the truth of the moment and I
relate so much to Ben I talked to
Randall before we started filming and I
said
Ben is me before I went to therapy and
I think there's a lot of things in Ben
that a lot of us can relate to and yes
of course he is
incredibly cynical and uh just hyper
critical at times but at the end of the
day there's a heart inside of him that
is unfortunately wrought with a lot of
insecurity and Paralyzed by his own
perfectionism but hopefully that full
sort of humanity is seen on screen
for him you rule for him because you've
been him Justin H man when I went to ADR
we had to do some together and by then I
was just sobbing in his arms and I was
like just and you're so good this guy is
born to play this character
these two are gonna just blow you away I
was just so moved and so touched and so
just
proud of these three
and the entire cast I mean it really is
I mean this is a it's a performance
piece you know I mean it is really about
the performance of of the cast and I
would say from top to bottom even like
in the smallest roles like we just
I mean it just goes to show how
incredible a director I am yeah because
no no because no no but truly because I
chose these actors who are just so
perfect for for their parts and uh and
so talented and also so kind you know
and that was important to me uh uh so
yeah I'm just a great director
[Laughter]
honestly we loved Randall as a director
it was just enough truly you it just
blew us away on set because it's like
you knew exactly what you want but then
somehow you like let us play
effortlessly so it make it made it feel
like it was our own but then you always
knew exactly what your vision was and
never strayed from that and that was
very impressive
one of the things about this movie is
movies actually play a big part of the
film you work at a movie theater movies
are discussed all the time so can you
sort of talk about that aspect
um uh because can you talk about that
aspect of the importance of movies in
the movie
well Ben is a cinephile and uh and you
know it's a part of his uh uh it's a
part of his nature to be very particular
about what's good and what's bad and uh
and he has his ideas of what's good and
what's bad and uh uh so we explore
those films that he finds both good and
really bad you know uh uh and uh uh yeah
in a lot of ways it is a movie about
movies you know and and and their
meaning to to us as a culture but also
as a community the uh you know what
these movies mean how they how they
help us Define ourselves and how some of
us bristle to that
yeah
I want to talk about a specific but I
can't
um I will say I'm going to talk around
something but there's a sequence in the
movie theater with some of the people
working there talking about another
movie where it's playing on the actors
that are in the scene
um I don't want to say it has to do with
a superhero movie I don't want to I
don't want to say anything specifically
beyond that but it's like but it's very
funny but it's also like uh so talk a
little bit about that sequence without
talking I mean man it's really effing
tough
you know what I'm talking about though
yeah yeah well we have again incredible
actors uh Jacob batalon uh Scott sice uh
uh who are employed by by Justin's
character Ben at this movie theater and
uh again it's like what do I mean for me
it was all about what's real what what
you'd expect to happen in these
situations and you know movie folks who
work in a movie theater are likely
passionate about movies themselves as as
Ben is and and and and and uh and they
have they have their thoughts on movies
and and there's some Meta Meta stuff
going on there and uh
and they're just I I mean those two were
just so funny and were such great uh
actors with their lines but also
improvisers and and we used a lot of
what uh a lot of their play yeah um for
people when they watch the movie you'll
understand what I'm talking about it's a
very very funny sequence
um so listen obviously uh this is not a
Marvel movie there's a limited time and
budget that you have to make this so it
could become one if they you know so
Randall Park cinematics
but I am curious though when you're
looking at the schedule
um what were you most concerned about
being able to pull off with the time and
budget that you had and did for you guys
did you ever feel any sort of pressure
on set because maybe you have to you
know you only have two three takes and
you got to move on
um I I yeah I I it was I kind of knew of
all the challenges going in because I
had a lot of
friends who are director who are
directors and they gave me a lot of
advice and our great team uh just you
know who've made multiple films
just educated me on what to expect so I
knew of the limitations and in a lot of
ways I I felt like those limitations
were kind of blessings in a way you know
because we kept it moving and we uh uh
and again going back to Casting
thankfully you know
I had such professional
skilled actors to work with so that it's
like we didn't have to do so many takes
because they gave us everything you know
in the in the few takes that we had and
uh and and a great DP in Santiago
Gonzalez who who really like just helped
us he was so confident and and helped us
kind of
keep it moving you know I think like and
Randall's saying the limitations kind of
pushed us and kept us Vigilant in a
sense is a testament to Asian Americans
in Hollywood you know the scarcity the
lack of representation like
here we go no but I was gonna say it was
a true Indie a labor of love which is
why you know World premiering at
Sundance is so much more Victorious and
flavorful you know it's so sweet because
we know what we had to do to make this
beautiful film you know yeah and I think
in terms of pacing I I really loved it
because first of all I think we had so
much material to work with in advance we
had Adrian's amazing novel so I think we
had so much backstory and then you know
these two we just I mean Sherry and I
are basically from the same womb yeah
and Justin hmit is like just an icon
look at this sweater yeah we got the
23andMe results we're all related and we
all just cared so much about these
characters in this story and I also
think shooting in New York brings a
different energy of like it was so much
fun to shoot because we're just in the
streets of the West Village our trailers
are on the side of the street you you go
out in the bustle it just it's going and
you can't stop like the people that are
coming in we actually had radio man show
up on in one of my do you know who this
is is that the Naked Cowboy no no he's
been in like 150 films and he showed up
on one of the days that we were doing
the scene riding his bike through the
scene he's in it he's in the movie and I
think they say if he's in your movie
it's like it's a good luck oh so good to
know thank you radio man yeah I think in
New York I think it actually proved true
since you were sitting here at Sundance
with it
he's throwing that out there yes the
Good Vibes 100 New Year weekend by the
way let's go year of the rabbit let's go
let's go
the two of you are really really great
together on screen uh and I enjoyed the
dynamic so much
um talk a little bit about working
together and uh because you guys have
such different personalities in the
movie and but your best friends and so
supportive
I think that's a reflection of real life
as well because we could not be more
different
just opposite extremes as Justin and
Sherry as well but it works we operate
the same like we just we're just with it
you know tell me tell me good things
about me
[Laughter]
you can have
a wrong seed with Sherry in it it's so
much fun uh Randall gave us the freedom
to do a lot of improv so she would just
go off on one of her improvs and I would
just start cracking up laughing we've
ruined a lot of takes yeah yeah it was
the entire budget of the film actually
went to your take
budget is just footage for my real yes
absolutely but it was a lot of fun so
much fun so much fun and I had just done
a movie with his cousin Ashley Park so
it's just I'm part of the family now
this is all family and Justin is just I
mean he's my emergency contact
um and uh I'm gonna be his surrogate you
know we have that's I didn't want to
announce that today but
surprise
news coming out of Sunday you never know
what's gonna happen
this is the first interview of the day
okay got it got it got it got it baby
steps uh I have to wrap with you in a
second but I have to ask you a jokey
question
um and bear with me uh so you're
obviously in the Ant-Man uh you're in
Marvel and then you may have been given
a role in the Aquaman sequel did you
feel like you were cheating uh when you
made when you took that part I'm joking
around
I'm here to talk about shortcuts
but like you know directing acting uh
but you're one of the few that gets to
do both universes oh yeah yeah I I to
this day don't know how it happened uh
but I feel very lucky yeah yeah because
I love both you know that was a true
verse
that's the top and the bottom of it
the power of editing oh sorry
as I'm cutting everyone off hot I'm I'm
just going to say and I mean this
sincerely congrats on being part of
Sundance and I really I really would
have loved to have talked more
specifically about the film and this you
know what I mean but um that's for when
the movie is out and can follow up with
more specific questions and I'm just
gonna say really enjoy the festival
thank you so much great way to kick it
off
um yeah there's so much I want to talk
about oh my God